Now by now you've heard that the
Senate's no longer enforcing its own
dress code let's just come around
whatever they want including the
standard fetterman uniform a hoodie and
gym shorts
well I mean I I feel it's you know a
little more freedom which should be
bipartisanship you know what I'm saying
so but I don't know why the right side
seems to be losing their minds over it
like ah dogs and cats are living
together and you know like the world's
spinning off its axis but you know I
think it's a good thing
of course this is all about lowering the
bar for fettermen but the point here
isn't the dress code really it's that
Pennsylvania has a senator who literally
refuses to dress like an adult when he
represents adults I think it's actually
quite endearing he wants to be
comfortable he's not comfortable in the
other side he has a suit let's be very
clear about that he will wear shorts as
much as he can but when he has to wear a
suit he will wear a suit how many times
has he actually done that well anytime
we see that he's standing in a Podium he
looks like he just got done working out
so she's comfortable well let's be clear
you don't dress up in court or in the
senate or in any professional setting to
make yourself feel better you do it out
of respect and because you have a better
chance of persuading other people to do
what you want them to do when you look
and act professionally
wearing a suit shows a certain amount of
respect for the process and the other
people in your workplace when you don't
show that respect you're signaling that
you just are not serious
we might be seeing more of John
fetterman's hoodies and shorts on the
senate floor but yeah I think this is a
step forward I just don't understand why
you have to do the business of Congress
which you know incredibly long hours
incredibly demanding I don't think it
requires a suit
now why isn't she just wearing a bathing
suit on TV then probably more
comfortable fetterman is apparently
indicated to his fellow Senators that he
can't do his job without these special
accommodations
that act in and of itself is going to
cause his fellow Senators to take him
less seriously if that's even possible
now this isn't because the Senators are
bad people or because they're mean or
because they don't care about people who
suffer from whatever condition oppresses
him it's simply an act of human
psychology if everyone else is following
the rules and you say that you can't or
won't people are just going to take you
less seriously
so suit or not fetterman can still help
Schumer and Biden he can vote how they
tell him to vote and do what they tell
him to do he can still help the media he
can still vote for whatever causes they
want him to vote for and they'll keep
helping him as long as they can
but for you pennsylvanians out there he
can't help and wearing a hoodie won't
change that federman's not capable of
brokering big deals with other members
or doing the type of work that voters
expect of their senators
because he likes someone like Dianne
Feinstein is simply another vote for
Chuck Schumer to cast however he sees
fit
though Pennsylvania deserves a heck of a
lot better
of course fetterman supporters in the
media they promised the voters of
Pennsylvania that none of this would
happen
they promised that Senator fetterman
could be just as productive just as
effective as any other Senator out there
well that was obviously not true and it
was never going to be true
the whole thing is outrageous but I'm
not going to waste my time waiting for
any apology
and here's another thought Schumer now
has as much power as any Senator that I
can ever remember and I've been here a
long time
he casts three votes his own plus the
votes of Feinstein and fetterman no one
in his caucus ever disagrees with them
at least not publicly
at least 35 Republicans remain under
McConnell's thumb as well and McConnell
he's doing everything he can to help
Schumer beat Trump and the House
Republicans
Shimmer's enormous power is at the root
of almost every major problem we face
today
none of the things we care about from
the woke military to the war in Ukraine
to what we talked about earlier with Dan
Patrick the open border nightmare that
we're all dealing with this never-ending
budget deficit none of that is going to
improve as long as the Senate is just a
rubber stamp for Chuck Schumer
Republicans have almost 50 seats now in
the Senate and every one of those people
they were elected on the grounds that
they would form an effective opposition
to Chuck Schumer an effective opposition
to the Democrats but instead sadly
unbelievably most of them are still
focused on fighting people like I don't
know what Marjorie Taylor green Vivek
ramaswamy
that all needs to change hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else